so if we want to think scientifically
about cooking we have to start by
thinking a little bit about what food is
made out of because after all it is the
constituents of food which will be the
major player in this adventure that
we're about to launch ourselves on let's
just start with the very basic fact
which is that all of us and all of our
food is made of molecules now there are
simple molecules there's the molecules
that's in the air around us there's for
example carbon dioxide there's oxygen
there's water
these are simple molecules they contain
a of course themselves are components of
atoms so carbon dioxide is composed of
carbon and oxygen water is composed of
hydrogen and oxygen and so on food
molecules are more complex than atoms
and there are also more complex than
simple molecules the molecules are
cooking namely fats proteins and
carbohydrates tend to be much larger
molecules which themselves also contain
atoms such as carbon nitrogen oxygen and
so on and one of the unusual things
about cooking is is that the basic
molecules are through the basic fats the
basic sugars that we will talk about
tend to form very large networks you
know or sort of agglomerated structures
which are what you know make up the
structure of food and also actually for
that matter of us so let's just start
with fats so fats are very common so
examples of common fats and that you
might eat with include olive oil coconut
oil cocoa butter shortening and that has
you know sort of two features that I
that I would like to highlight right now
so the first is is that fats can either
be in liquid or in solid form at room
temperature and indeed there are fats
that are liquids there are fats that are
solids at room temperature so the second
feature of fats is that fats don't
dissolve in water that's why when you
take try to make salad dressing and you
mix oil and water for example olive oil
and water you will notice that the olive
oil does not actually mix itself in the
water and even if you take your bottle
of olive olive oil and water and shake
it up rapidly they will if you let it
sit for a while on the countertop
separate em into the oil being on top
and the water being beneath it and that
is because oil and water
mix with each other they said
differently what oil doesn't dissolve in
in water now this is sort of one of the
defining features of oil and it is very
different than the two other major
components of food so now let's talk a
little bit about carbohydrates so
carbohydrates consists basically if
sugars you know sucrose you know the
sweet taste that you tend to eat if
you're trying to eat something sweet and
also chains of sugars which are starches
you know we're sort of longer chain
sugars and these are the sort of two
main types of carbohydrates that exist
in your food
so either sugars or sugar chains now
sugars actually have their own
interesting properties so one property
of sugar which at least I find
interesting is that sugar is really a
very hard substance that is if you try
to scratch it a solid sugar piece of
sugar it's it's very difficult to do so
for example imagine taking rock candy
rock candy is really a solid it doesn't
squish at all and compare that to either
your skin you know or to jello or to
something like that which is tends to be
squishy sugar is very hard and this
hardness as we will discover in this
class is a property of the molecules and
that make it up so the other thing which
is interesting about sugar is that sugar
dissolves very well in water the
solubility limit of sugar is two pounds
per pound and that's really sort of
remarkable a remarkable property of
sugars so as I said actually the other
main type of carbohydrate are starches
and starches are what we call polymers
that is chains of sugar molecules so
what you do is you take simple sugar
molecules like glucose or sucrose and
you put them together in long chains and
those chains are what makes up starches
so examples include for example amylose
which is a polymer of glucose monomers
so you take a bunch of glucose monomers
and stick them together end by end to
make a long chain and that makes up
amylose or there is what people call
amylopectin which is the same thing
except instead of being a linear chain
like polymer it's actually branched so
there are branches of polymer that are
coming off of it in different ways in
this course many of our chefs will
introduce you to new molecules like for
example Agra Ferran adrià is a great fan
of agar agar agar
there's pectin there's guar gum there's
methyl cellulose there's jell n there's
xantham gum there's a huge host of
molecules which all are actually
carbohydrates so whereas flour is made
by from wheat by milling and grinding
wheat you know guar gum actually comes
from plants agar comes from seaweeds
Gellin and xanthan gum come from
microbes and there's a whole host of
different molecules that are made by
organisms on our planet that and we can
use and we do use as part of our foods
and we will see in the course of this
class that that remarkable things can be
made when you enlarge the set of
molecules that's at your disposal so now
I want to turn to the third major
component of food which is proteins so
proteins of course occur in many of the
things that you eat so for example if
you look at a piece of steak the red
color and steak comes from hemoglobin at
least in part which is a protein
constituent of blood so milk actually
has a protein in it that is called
Casson
albumin is a protein component of eggs
which is the thing that is responsible
really for the remarkable properties of
eggs when you heat and you cook them
this is something that we will talk
about extensively in this class and
proteins when considered as a molecule
have their own interesting property
which is distinct from that of either
fats or carbohydrates and that is the
following so proteins dissolve in water
and that's the same as carbohydrates but
what proteins do that is different is
that when you heat up water or you heat
up the protein by a relatively small
amount you know say 50 degrees Celsius
even is often enough you can get the
protein to change conformation the
protein is an active molecule it doesn't
keep the same shape as you cook it and
indeed it is the changes in shape and
configuration of proteins that arguably
are really at the heart of most of
cooking when you apply heat or other
means as we will again see and
throughout this class so what is a
protein so a protein is also a polymer
it's a polymer in the same way that the
starch molecules that I described before
polymers except in this case
instead of the monomers all being
identical for example being you know a
glucose or a simple sugar molecule
proteins are polymers of amino acids and
it turns out that there are 20 different
types of amino acids that compose the
proteins that are part of life as we
know it and these 20 amino acids these
20 monomers themselves have different
physical properties some of them
dissolved in water some of them don't
dissolve in water some of them have
electric charge some of them don't have
electric charge and as we go through
this class we will start to see how the
different components of proteins give
rise to the transformations that occur
when we cook them what happens when you
cook a protein when you heat a protein
is that the long strand tends to unfold
into a long extensible polymer so one
can unfold and much of cooking it turns
out is related to the transformation in
which a protein in a given food is
actually extended into a long polymer
and when it does that then it turns out
that the polymers that is the different
proteins that are in the food tend to
stick to each other and they sort of
coagulate and you form a gelatinous mass
and that process the changing of a
protein from a compact shape to a big
gelatinous mass of many proteins
interacting is you know at the heart of
cooking an egg it's at the heart of
making jello it's at the heart of many
of the food transformations that we will
see in this class and these can occur as
we will see both by applying heat or by
applying changes in pH by actually using
acid Monbiot lemon juice or vinegar or
by changing the salt concentration and
so these are the various knobs that are
at play with proteins when you cook